what's going on at number 10 i'm i'm i'm
a headspin and i have no idea where we
are okay
so they're basically
the reason your head spinning is is
meant to spin they tell us different
things on different days that's the
problem and as time goes on the truth
starts to come out and now we have a
civil servant who's furious about the
way in which they have been telling lies
but essentially when christopher pincher
was a junior minister in the foreign
office there were allegations saying
that he had been guilty of inappropriate
behavior there was an investigation done
internally and it was found to be
substantiated that they had been
behaving inappropriately we don't know
what that means
but we do know that the that the his
boss knew and that was dominic robb and
we knew that you know the prime minister
knew and what happened was that the guy
was promoted he suddenly he became
housing minister instead and then he
ends up being one of the whips and so
it's as if it didn't matter and i just
think about that poor victim who came
forward and spoke about what
pincher had done to him
and and it's dismissed as
unsubstantiated one day and then when it
is substantiated they go oh well there's
no there were no live allegations at the
time so it's either unsubstantiated when
they're investigating it or it's in the
past once they have whatever happens
it's not important as far as they're
concerned because they're looking after
their own and their friend they're
they're quite happy to just lie about it
you know we had quite a robust
conversation with mr rob in the last
hour and he made the point that the
person that had made the allegation
didn't want it to go any further i said
well could be for all sorts of reasons
he acknowledged that but he said that
they didn't want to take it any further
and that he had been spoken to in very
strong terms mr pincher and told not to
do it again
subsequent claims we don't know if they
are true or not you're innocent until
proven guilty
and they had the deputy chief whip who
wasn't allowed out without a minder you
know that's what they accept they accept
that he had a minder you have an mp who
can't be allowed out on their own and
their deputy chief whip
that's what this party is that's what
this government is based on
you know and then the prime minister
just lies about it and just goes oh well
i just know about generalized
allegations i don't know about anything
we don't know that he knew anything
specific do we well we know that there
was an investigation done by the cabinet
office and we know that it was found to
be a substantiated allegation there was
something to it there was something in
it
and that that was then told to his boss
we've heard today from dominic rabb that
he told the man off and they didn't go
any further than that and then the prime
minister makes a decision about
promoting him to housing secretary
housing minister i think sorry
yeah but it was it was several years
later is what would being led to believe
that uh when it was the second time ryan
when he was going to be deputy chief
whip that the prime minister potentially
might have known i mean it seemed
complicated trying to explain it uh he
might have known uh what had happened
but he nevertheless dominic rabb said he
was a brilliant um minister and as a
result um he should be in the position
yeah we hear all sorts of things and we
hear about his former spin doctor the
prime minister's former spin doctor
saying that the prime minister used to
call him pincher by name i mean yeah but
we don't have all of this that's hearsay
we hear all of this
absolutely absolutely but we keep
hearing that there are allegations that
are substantiated and there are further
allegations it goes on and on the man is
not allowed to be a minister theresa may
takes a different view boris johnson
kind of shrugs his shoulders you know
and you just wonder this how much more
of this do we need you know this comes
on the back of how many scandals have we
had you know what about the previous one
with the last one can't even remember
what the last one oh the last one was
his uh his wife girlfriend at the time
he wanted her to get this job a hundred
thousand pounds in the legend
allegedly another one allegedly you know
we hear this and he's trying to promote
her into that so that you know that we
have that we have you know one thing
after another after another and what we
essentially say is we shrug our
shoulders and we go well we know our
prime minister's a liar just like how it
is your party's not without guilt is it
can you imagine the leader of any other
party behaving like that no i'm thinking
about giving any you know any any any
laxity at all nothing i'm thinking about
eric joyce 2020 convicted of child sex
offences and this year former labor peer
lord ahmed jail for five and a half
years for sexually abusing two children
yeah what on earth is going on in that
chamber over there
i think there is a culture in parliament
which is completely unacceptable i've
been there for 17 18 years now and there
is certainly a culture of misogyny and
bullying and senior people taking
advantage of more junior people and i
think there is a minority of people who
who go much further than just simply
bullying and misogyny and and there is a
an exploitation i think of junior people
and it's disgraceful what we have to do
is we have to deal with it person by
person individual by individual and the
way that we do it is by being honest and
straightforward and showing a bit of
leadership and that's what we don't get
at the moment when should the police get
involved
i think the police should get involved
when there is a when there is a serious
allegation i think that's what should
always happen so should they be involved
with the pincher case i don't know how
serious it is i i mean i i don't i see
there's the problem is that we don't
know how serious no we don't know so you
know we don't hear it hang drawing
quartering the man and we don't know how
serious the allegations are well
we know that there is a
there have been a series of allegations
over
over a long period of time
and we know that he that they decided
that the best thing to do with him was
to not let him out without a minder so
you're suggesting this potentially a
pattern i'm putting to you given what
we've been saying from both sides of the
house and the the situation that uh
youngsters find themselves in the unions
are saying it's not a safe place to work
should the police start to get involved
with mr pinscher to find out exactly
what did go on and you have to accept
what the outcome is
yeah yeah i mean
i think that if there have been serious
allegations made i think the police
should be involved i mean i just think
they should i don't think there's any
there's any other way around it i mean
it has to be it has to be you know
we can't just say this is okay because
it's not okay it's not okay for this to
keep happening it's not okay
what do you think has happened as far as
mr pincher is concerned in the prime
minister what do you think he knew
i think the prime minister knew that he
relied on mr pincher because when there
was this rebellions he's been relying on
pinscher to help him as a as a whip to
kind of keep his position so he's been
he's been essentially just turning a
blind eye to any allegations because it
suited the prime minister to turn a
blind eye to it and the prime minister
is not exactly the first person to have
the highest standards of personal
behavior and he turns a blind eye to
other people do you think
if durham police find that your leader
does deserve a fixed penalty notice that
the nec should turn a blind eye to his
suggestion that he should step down or
do you think he should be honorable and
step down so he's going to stand down
yeah he's going to stand up but then nec
doesn't have to accept that i mean he's
going to stand down and he said he's
going to stand down it's perfectly clear
i mean he was asked about it yesterday
and said if i get a fire from durham
police i will stand down what a
difference what a difference what a
contrast to our prime minister but he's
not going to happen anyway because he
hasn't done anything wrong well you
don't know well i do know he hasn't done
it well we have to wait and see what
we'll have to wait and see what the
police say if he gets a fixed penalty
notice even if he doesn't accept that he
deserves it he says that he's going to
step down no no that's right that's what
he said
does it need given what we've been
talking about about the um
situation i was trying to tip her
through the raindrops then on how to
describe the chamber of the house of
commons but do we need does labour need
a smart sassy woman like you to lead
them
no well we just kiss dharma to be the
next prime minister and we need a
country that is led by a decent and
honorable person and that's what we have
in kierstarma you know it does help us
in the labor party that we have 50
percent more than 50 of our mps are
women i think that the culture in the
labor party has changed as a result of
that i think that there's you know just
in terms of mathematics you know it's
better but i think in terms of the
culture in terms of the challenge it's
much clearer and stronger because we are
you know a more equal party than we have
been before and the boys club boys club
my question was would you stand
kier is not going to stand down because
kira is not going to get fined but if
he's not but he's not going to
it it doesn't even arise he's not going
to get fined because he hasn't done
anything wrong he's going to lead the
labor party to the next general election
and i hope that the british public give
us permission to serve them so that's
not a no then we'll have to wait and see
what happens as far as it's not going to
happen it's not well we'll see you don't
know you don't have a crystal ball and
if you do you could tell me what's going
to win the 3 45 at haydock um kiersten
was saying yesterday that labour
wouldn't rejoin the single market how
does that make you feel
well i mean
it's realistic you know leaving the
european union was a one-way street
we're not going to be able even if we
even if the british public said oh yes
let's have another two years of fighting
about this and another referendum we
wouldn't be able to join rejoin the
european union on the same terms that we
were members before we'd have to join
the euro we wouldn't be able to get our
rebate we would we would have to join
schengen which is all about you know
protecting our borders you know all of
these things would change we wouldn't be
able to go back in the way that we were
so we are where we are now are you
falling in line now no what i'm saying
is is that i'm a pragmatic politician
and i know that in 2019 we were defeated
we had to leave and so now that we've
left we have to look after our country
and make sure that the right decisions
are being made
i want us to have a great future as a
country i believe that we can but we
can't do it by pretending that there
aren't issues with the european union at
the moment we need to be able to export
our cheese to europe we need to have a
veterinary agreement we need to agree
that we have the same food standards as
the rest of europe i have no idea why
the government refuses to have a
veterinary agreement with europe i mean
new zealand does why can't we you know
with there are a number of things we
need to sort out with europe they're our
nearest neighbors they're the ones we do
most of our trade with but they say oh
we've done brexit we're not going to
bother with any of the problems that
continue to plague us let alone having
no idea as to what to do in in terms of
northern ireland i was just about to say
out with five points that uh kyo starman
says he's going to use to fix brexit one
of them being the northern ireland
protocol i was going to ask you how to
fix it and then i thought that's going
to take two hours and we don't sorry yes
yes yes maybe we'll do that but we need
a plan that's the point we need a plan
and labor has one come back in our nine
o'clock hour one of these days and we'll
talk about it in much more detail when
we've got more time i'd love to thank
you very much indeed thank you